[Musique]
zemmour eric 63 ans candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avec votre
nouveau parti reconquête c'est votre
première campagne bonjour et bienvenue
eric zemmour bonjour nous allons donc
voyager dans les archives de l'ina pour
tenter de cerner votre adn
[Musique]
première apparition à la télévision 95
et 37 ans éditorialiste à info matin
vous venez d'écrire un livre sur edouard
balladur immobile à grands pas et
michèle cotta vous inviter à sa revue de
presse sur france 2 tous les hommes
politiques ont à peu près les mêmes
idées et que tous pensent exactement à
peu près ce qu'il faut faire mais la
différence est là nous devons nous
adapter et eux mêmes doivent s'adapter
c'est que la différence va se faire sur
la façon de le faire c'est à dire sur le
style sur la clé permet d'apporter ma
mais la défense clermontoise
qui existe non parce qu'il ya manière et
manière d'apporter ses remèdes il ya la
manière lente douce
qui qui est plutôt prudente et il ya la
manière en forme de rupture avec l'un
des otages mais si ça change beaucoup
c'est un moment de fête mais si ça
dépend comment le fait
même parti socialiste
d'un accord par exemple on dit réduction
des charges sociales ya manière et
manière de le faire
brusquement est ce qu'on veut c'est
enrichissant sur dix ans c'est pas la
mauvaise c'est intéressant parce que
vous ramenez les politiques à une
question de style à une différence de
forme vous ne diriez plus aujourd'hui
deux choses d'abord
quel point j'étais mal habillée c'est
j'ai un peu hot rétrospectivement
première chose deuxième chose
[Musique]
nous sommes en 95 vous l'avais dit après
donc nous sommes trois ans après
maastricht après le référendum sur
maastricht après
si vous voulez je pense que ce que je
dis à l'époque et est tout à fait
conforme à la réalité c'est à dire qu'à
partir de maastricht il n'y a plus de
vraie différence entre la droite et la
gauche
vous savez vous connaissez le mot
célèbre de philippe séguin la droite et
la gauche sont des
dés
comment dire des comment il disait des
boutiques et où des dans des dédales des
détaillants qui se fournissent au même
grossiste l'europe donc ce que j'ai
voulu dire là c'est ça c'est à dire que
l'europe la construction européenne
maastricht
les les pertes de souveraineté que cela
a occasionné la mondialisation tout cela
rares
fait ressembler les politiques fait à se
rapprocher les cons les politiques et
que tout est question de forme donc
effectivement pourquoi je ne le dirais
plus aujourd'hui je ne le dirais plus
aujourd'hui non pas parce que c'est faux
puisque sur les politiques économiques
franchement ça n'a jamais été aussi vrai
et d'ailleurs tous les français ont fini
par se rendre compte de cela je me
rappelle que déjà dans la campagne de
2002 jean pierre chevènement disait
chose rack pour dire jospin et chirac
c'était la même chose
donc c'est une réalité qui a petit à
petit petit à petit s'est imposé on sait
bien que françois hollande a été très
critiqué à gauche parce qu'il faisait
finalement la même politique que la
droite et la droite a été très critiquée
aussi par ce que il faisait la même
politique que la gauche donc je dirais
toujours cela mais en revanche la
nouveauté et c'est sans doute le
justement le sens de ma candidature
c'est que je pense que nous sommes
sortis de la discussion économique et
que nous sommes rentrés dans la
discussion identitaire c'est à dire que
ce n'est plus la question n'est plus
comme depuis l'après guerre jusqu'aux
années 90 comment on répartit la
richesse comment on répartit la
croissance plus ou moins comment l'état
intervient plus ou moins dans l'économie
bref on est sorti d'une discussion
économique et social
comprenez-moi bien ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya plus de questions économiques
il n'y a plus de questions sociales il
savait tout ça existe encore mais comme
comme coeur selon moi de la vie du pays
c'est la question identitaire qui se
pose la question de la survie de la
france de la question du grand
emplacement toutes ces questions que
j'ai posées dans cette présidentielle et
qui pour moi vont déterminent le destin
de la france dans les décennies à venir
on va reparler de politique mais on va
continuer de dérouler le fil de vos
apparitions télé de votre carrière
médiatique épisode décisif la parution
en 2006 d'un essai sous forme de
pamphlet le premier sexe qui vous donne
l'occasion de ferrailler sur les
plateaux de télévision et notamment sur
celui de thierry ardisson face à la
militante féministe clémentine autain
psychologie fait masculine
quand on admire une femme on a d'autant
plus de mal à désirer c'est l'éternel
masculin à partir du moment où c'est
pour ça que les hommes inventent des
parades des parades machi c'est pour ça
qu'ils inventent la prostitution c'est
pour ça qu'ils inventent des d un cinéma
en fait ma machiste pour oublier qu'ils
aiment et qu'ils admirent parce que
c'est un bal explique magnifiquement que
quand on aime une femme on n'ose pas la
toucher on l'a on l'a divinise on l'a
sacralisée c'est l'amer dirait freud
gâteau
c'est l'émission qui a changé votre
destin médiatique le cours de votre vie
on peut dire ça oui pour une raison
simple c'est d'abord que le livre a eu
un grand succès et que
dans les spectateurs de cette émission
il y avait
catherine barma qui était la productrice
d'ardisson et qui était aussi la
productrice de laurent ruquier donc
c'est ce qui l'a incité à me proposer
quelques mois plus tard d'être
chroniqueur dans l'émission qui
commençait en septembre 2006 et on n'est
pas couché et qui effectivement m'a fait
connaître au grand public mais c'est
intéressant de revoir ça parce que je
pense que
vous savez je je je vis je m'inscris
tout à fait dans une tradition
journalistique française si vous voulez
résumé je pense qu'il y a 2 tradition
journalistique la tradition
journalistique anglo saxon qui
privilégie le fait la recherche du fait
voir du scoop et la tradition française
journalistique française qui repose sur
le mot sur l'élégance de la phrase sur
le mot qui claque le pamphlet une
tradition française qui s'enracine très
loin dans le passé on peut on pourrait
faire naître d'ailleurs ça dans le
fameux texte vous savez de pascal qui
défend ses amis janséniste persécuté par
les jésuites et par le roi avec un brio
indépassable c'est toute la tradition
française qui remonte de 2 pascal à
voltaire azzola voyez à léon daudet de
droite et de gauche 1 l'important étant
le
mots qui claquent le mot qui qui qui
saigne et je pense que je suis je suis
l'héritier un héritier pardon de cette
tradition là est ce ce livre est tout à
fait typique de cette tradition
française du du pamphlet de voiliers du
texte qui qui qui qui pousse qui pousse
dans ses retranchements et qui est là
pour pour faire réfléchir par la la la
l'élégance du verbe enfin en tout cas le
côté spectaculaire du verbe c'est vrai
mais
sur le fond du sujet votre propos c'est
à dire l'image des femmes la place des
femmes tout cela occupé dans ces années
là une place de choix dans vos saillie
polémique sur les plateaux
les hommes font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour réaliser ce programme ambitieux
devenir une femme comme les autres les
valeurs dominantes dans la société puis
sont adoptées par les hommes sont toutes
des valeurs traditionnellement féminines
vous savez bien c'est la paix pas la
guerre le consensus pas l'autorité le la
précaution pas le risque etc et on voit
pour la politique c'est très intéressant
les femmes arrivées dans une profession
au même moment le pouvoir désertent la
politique vous dit l'homme est un
prédateur sexuel un conquérant mais
c'est une incitation au viol ça non au
viol non pas du tout ah bah non en
prédateur sexuel saignant des mots qui
sont loin d'en charger mais tout à fait
vous avez tout à fait raison je continue
à penser qu'il y à de la violence dans
le rapport sexuel entre mes fans c'est
une violence civilisé en se levant il me
dit ah mais vous allez me remerciez
autrement et là il me faut à sa langue
dans ma bouche il assez inattendu des
coûtants immonde diable quel raccourci
je
je ne sais pas qui est cette dame
est c'est une des logiciels qui vous
accuse oui absolument
je passe je viens de déposer contre vous
je le précise eddy merckx avait 6 et
mais pourquoi avoir seulement répondu
que cela relevait de votre vie privée
parce que je n'ai jamais agressé deux
femmes on veut on veut faire passer si
vous voulez on veut un continuum entre
un comportement qui est apparemment mis
en cause et des réflexions
moi je si vous voulez je ne considère
que je n'ai jamais agressé deux femmes
c'est tout maintenant c'est d'ailleurs
assez comment vous dire c'est grave de
faire cela parce que
ça ça mme
saad
comment vous dire ça les vraies femmes
agressées du coup ça relativise les
vrais agression voyez les mots ne
veulent plus rien dire c'est ça que je
veux dire bon maintenant je vais pas me
m'étaler sur sur cesser ces pseudos
dénonciation je vous laisse sur le fond
sur le fond il n'y a rien de choquant
dans ce que j'ai dit c'est simplement
j'analysais des comportements
j'analysais des imaginaires j'analysais
ddd sociologie une évolution jauge
opposaient des valeurs dites masculines
à des valeurs dites féminines et la
prévalence dans la société contemporaine
des valeurs dites féminines qui peuvent
s qui sont porté d'ailleurs par des
femmes mais aussi par des hommes et qui
sont les valeurs de paix de consensus
comme je les dis dans mes interventions
c'est un constat que que font beaucoup
de gens j'ai vu j'ai pas eu le temps de
le lire malheureusement parce que je
n'ai plus le temps beaucoup lire pendant
cette campagne mais j'ai vu qu'emmanuel
todd université reconnue à gauche
reprend à peu près les mêmes analyses
dans son dernier livre
et ça n'a rien de particulièrement à
l'époque c'était plus original c'est
tout avec beaucoup de critiques aussi
parler bien sûr bien sûr bertone vous
avez raison et vous avez raison de
réponse féministe mais pas seulement
votre éclosion politique maintenant en
images elle date du 28 septembre 2019
quand vous prenez la parole à la
convention la droite de marion maréchal
c'est votre première tribune politique
les jeunes français vont-ils accepter de
vivre en minorité sur la terre de leurs
ancêtres
si oui ils méritent leur colonisation
sinon ils devront se battre pour leur
libération alors ce n'est pas vous faire
insulte de que de dire que vous êtes
loin de la posture du du tribun vous
avez dû apprendre depuis examinée j'ai
progressé en tout cas vous me
l'accorderez
moi vous savez quand je ne sais pas
faire quelque chose eh ben je réfléchis
je travaille je m'améliore j'ai toujours
fait comme ça pour tous est donc là
je trouvais ma map ma performance
pas à la hauteur de ce que de ce que ça
aurait dû être et donc depuis j'ai
travaillé j'ai je crois progresser vous
avez raison c'était mon premier discours
que vous pouvez appeler politique mais
accordez moi que lors des émissions on
va en parler lors des émissions par
exemple de heurter ou d'autres je
faisais déjà de la politique au sens de
de combat politique culturelle
voilà allons à présent explorer vos
racines
vos ancêtres eric zemmour sont nés en
algérie le décret crémieux de 1870 qui
accorde la citoyenneté aux israël it
indigènes d'algérie en fait des français
voici comment le professeur henry chez
mu dresse le portrait du juifs d'algérie
c'est une archive de 71 dans l'émission
de josy eisenberg la source de vie le
jeune fille d'algérie était un bon gars
sont
remplies d'un esprit de fraternité d'un
esprit je redirai république a essayé
que nous avait appris nos vieux
instituteur à l'école et que nous
transportions dans le dans notre vie
juive puisque il était difficile de la
transporter ailleurs nous la transporter
nous mais nous étions pas reçu ailleurs
avec le même amour que nous mettions
pour nous y présenter
le juif algérien en gros aussi
générosité
un certain humour il se permettait même
quelquefois c'est 36 juifs et
quelquefois aussi à l'occasion courage
mais ça je crois que c'est assez entré
dans l'histoire et on le sait n'est ce
pas il a participé à toutes les grandes
actions à toute la guerre en particulier
est toujours
avec son allant sa bonne humeur et son
amour du travail bien fait si j'ose dire
il a le travail bien fait je crois que
d'autres en parlerons c'était l'amour de
la france est ce que cela correspond à
notre portrait ou à celui de votre
famille ah c'est exact constat
vraiment c'est tout à fait cela l'amour
de la france l'amour
de l'histoire de france de la
littérature française un amour vraiment
sens sans limite et
sans réserve
oui des gens des gens profondément
gentil bon garçon il a raison des gens
qui ont de l'humour qui se moque d'eux
mêmes c'est ce qu'il appelle
antijuive c'est-à-dire et de la religion
oui oui exactement met de la distance de
l'humour
je pense que c'est ce qu'on a appris de
la france c'est à dire voyez
l'autodérision et qui est très juifs en
même temps c'est de l'humour juif on
connaît woody allen on connaît tous la
ce se mélange entre le l'esprit juif
d'autodérision et l'esprit français de
d'ironie voltairienne voyez ce mélange
des deux ça fait tout à fait l'état
d'esprit du juive d'algérie qui se moque
de lui-même qui se moquent volontiers
de ses limites de c2c de ses petits
travers et qui se bat pour la france il
l'a très bien dit ce monsieur
les mois mais mes mavs dans ma famille
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui sont qu'ils
ont été
soldats pendant la guerre 14 mon arrière
grand père mon arrière grand oncle et
soldats étaient à verdun l'hôte était
dans les dardanelles et mon père me
racontait cela je connaître toute cette
histoire oui un patriotisme chevillé au
corps je pense que
c'est très important et aussi une une
conscience aiguë des de ce qui s'est
passé en algérie c'est à dire de deux
voiliers de cette situation très
complexe entre
les français de france c'est à dire les
vrais pieds noirs les juifs d'algérie
qui se sont agrégées petit à petit
malgré certaines rebuffade
à cette population de pieds-noirs et
puis les les musulmans qui vivaient à
part et qui ont toujours refusé le
statut
comparable à celui qu'avait obtenu les
juifs d'algérie dans vos études
vous avez connu l'échec deux fois recalé
au concours d'entrée de l'ena l'école
nationale d'administration 80 et 81 vous
n'êtes pas le seul mais non c'est juste
un concours 1 on voit la sortie on
n'apprend pas grand chose bien il vaut
mieux rire jaune à van avant l'ena le
recrutement dans la haute fonction
publique soit vraiment par casque et
c'est une école qui est démocratique ils
savent tout ils savent tout mais le
problème c'est qu'ils en sont convaincus
outre au parisien/aujourd'hui en 95
jours pas avoir fait l'ena il faisait
encore c'est plutôt une force qu'un
désavantage
c'est l'apprentissage de la pohdh ans le
conformisme de la pensée il y en a qui
arrivent à s'en sortir mais
ce qui vous côtoyez à l'époque disent
que ça a été une blessure est ce que
c'est toujours le cas non faut pas
exagérer c'est il ya 40 ans mais ça a
été une blessure ça a été une blessure
absolument mais vous savez d'abord j'ai
un tempérament de gagneur j'aime je
déteste perdre que ça soit en sport que
ça soit ailleurs et puis en plus j'avais
l'habitude entre guillemets d'être
premier de la classe et vous savez tous
les gens qui se présentent à l'ena ce
sont des premiers de la classe donc
forcément il y en a qui qui qui l'on est
donc ils sont toujours premiers de la
classe et quand on l'a pas on se dit
pour une fois on n'a pas envoyé et était
conforme à ce qu'on avait été toute son
enfance donc c'est en cela c'est en cela
évidemment une blessure je ne le jeu ne
le nie pas mais vous voyez c'est la vie
et passer l'orage et voilà à l'eau a
coulé sous les ponts ggg j'ai fait
d'autres choses j'ai reçu reparti je
suis reparti à la base vous savez
j'étais journaliste de base j'étais payé
chez philippe tesson au smic et j'ai
gravi les échelons de nouveau alors
justement journalistes et à près de 2
philippe tesson pour vous vos débuts en
journalisme au quotidien de paris qui
présente ainsi sa nouvelle formule l'an
79 quelques années avant votre embauche
ce sera toujours le même esprit c'est à
dire une espèce de de tendance
permanente une provocation bien comprise
on a ce qu'on appelle propre provocation
ça veut dire incitation à la réflexion
ça veut dire le bon exercice du jugement
critique ça veut dire indépendance
d'esprit de tous les instants ça veut
dire façon claire et assez légères assez
facile de présenter les choses sans les
alourdir cet esprit là il restera le
même c'est celui qui a toujours présidé
aux gens que j'ai fait le quotidien
était sont une école de la provocation
dans le sens où ils dealent le dit c'est
à dire incitation à réfléchir c'est à
dire
légèreté élégance
sens critique il vous savez c'est ça
dans ce sens oui l'eau dit oui bien sûr
une école magnifique et je pense que
philippe tesson d'ailleurs ne recrute
pas les gens par hasard il les prend non
pas en fonction de leurs idées
politiques mais en fonction de leur
sensibilité de leur capacité à incarner
cet esprit mais c'est ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure en fait ce qu'il
advient de dire c'est ce que je vous ai
dit sur le journalisme français hérité
de pascal de voltaire etc c'est la même
chose avec des mots différents
je pense que je vais dit d'ailleurs un
jour on faisait le dernier journal du
19e siècle dans le bon sens du terme
voyez accepté y avait des plumes
formidable d'aidé dominique jamet des
pôles gilbert daydé philippe testons des
stéphane denis des gens qui vraiment
savait écrire qu'ils étaient des fines
lames à la fois littéraire et politique
et moi je
me suis inscrit naturellement dans dance
est dans ce courant là parce que d'abord
chez j'aimais ça depuis toujours
j'aimais salle avant avant de rentrer au
quotidien de paris je lisais les grands
écrivains français j'ai toujours voulu
écrire j'ai écrit des livres j'ai
présenté un manuscrit chez gallimard
dans les années 80 qui qui a qui n'a pas
été finalement édité voyez c'était
c'était en fait de jeu j'ai toujours
voulu être journaliste écrivain voilà
est donc dans cet esprit là donc pour
moi c'était assez naturel au quotidien
de paris d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé très
vite très vite ma place en 1989 une
affaire qui surgit dans l'actualité et
qui va changer votre regard et vos
convictions vous ne direz creil la
sphère du voile du voile islamique
l'objet du délit le foulard plus
précisément les ifs marocain que porte
fatima et leïla selon leurs convictions
musulmane
je crains en dieu
je crains de personnes simples vieux
supporter jusqu'à ma mort
fatima et leïla ont 14 et 13 ans elle
étudie le coran chez elle au tableau
noir depuis l'âge de 3 ans elles font
leurs cinq prières par jour mais leur
but dans la vie c'est aussi de réussir à
l'école
moi je veux continuer mes études je
travaillais fatima et leïla ne sont pas
exclues du collège georges avait semé
l'accès leur en ai refusé tant qu'elles
porteront le foulard pendant les cours
principe de laïcité oblige
est ce cette histoire ce moment qui font
de vous l'homme d'une idée ou d'une
obsession le péril musulman
en tout cas c'est effectivement avec
cette histoire que je comprends que les
choses ne vont pas se passer
non seulement comme je le croyais jusque
là mais comme cela s'était passé pour
les générations précédentes d'immigrés
c'est à dire
les polonais les italiens les espagnols
les portugais les asiatiques même dont
les années 70 et
nous n'étions pas des immigrés parce que
nous étions français mais c'était un peu
la même logique assimilationniste je
comprends que
l'assimilation à la française va buter
sur une autre machine assimilationniste
qui est beaucoup plus puissante en
vérité surtout que c'est le moment où la
france renonce à ses principes
assimilate assimilationniste qui est
l'islam et je comprends que
ça ne s'agit pas y avoir un affrontement
je ne théorise pas encore l'affrontement
des civilisations qui sera théorisée par
le team tonnes mais c'est un peu l'idée
je comprends qu'il ya sur notre sol deux
civilisations qui vont s'affronter vous
connaissez le le mot célèbre de malraux
casque une civilisation tous qui
s'agrège à une religion et à partir du
moment où
on a ces deux civilisations qui
s'affrontent ça ne peut que que mal se
terminer d'ailleurs on est en 1989 je ne
suis pas le seul à comprendre cela en
1990 donc quelques mois plus tard il y a
une grande convention
du rpr et de l'udf les deux partis de la
droite de l'époque il y à jacques chirac
il y à valéry giscard d'estaing il y à
alain juppé il y à françois bayrou il y
a françois léotard il ya le nicolas
sarkozy
et cette convention de la droite et sur
l'immigration et dans les conclusions de
cette convention du rpr et de l'udf il
est écrit que l'islam est incompatible
avec la france et qu on doit arrêter
l'immigration qu'on doit arrêter le
regroupement familial et alain juppé lui
même dit
la france ne peut pas être le seul où il
y a deux civilisations il ne peut pas y
avoir deux civilisations sur son sol ne
peut y avoir qu'une
donc c'est exactement tout ce que je dis
aujourd'hui trente ans plus tard je ne
dit pas autre chose
effectivement
parce que je pense que c'est que c'est
la vérité est que c'est le
la cause majeure du drame français
d'aujourd'hui c'est la cause majeure de
cette violence
qui qui qui s'est développée depuis en
france c'est la la la la base de 2,2 du
mal-être français de toutes ces enclaves
étrangères qui ont qui prolifèrent en
france et de 2
effectivement de
jeu si vous voulez je comprends à ce
moment là tout ce que je dis aujourd'hui
est que que je vais approfondir depuis
lors voilà voyons pour cette campagne
règle zemmour qui sont vos mentors
alors deux exemples puisés à l'étranger
d'abord donald trump qui a fait
l'essentiel de sa campagne de 2016 sur
une seule promesse
zéro tolérance contre les immigrés les
jours
devant ses partisans le candidat
réaffirme son principal argument de
campagne
construire un mur entre le mexique et
les états unis un mur qu'il ferait même
payer aux mexicains
les mexicains sont de bonnes personnes
de bons dirigeants mais ils vont payer
le mur will begin le premier jour nous
commencerons à travailler sur un mur
impénétrable
imposant grandes puissances
à la frontière du sud
est ce que vous êtes inspiré de sa
stratégie du message unique répétées de
bout en bout non vous savez s'il n'est
pas le seul
nicolas sarkozy déjà disait cela qu'il
fallait répéter un seul message
quelques-uns disons pour sarkozy oui oui
mais je veux dire voyez c'est un
classique de la présidentielle
d'ailleurs trump lui-même parlé aussi de
réindustralisation mais effectivement il
avait axé sa campagne là dessus je n'ai
pas attendu trump pour penser que
c'était la question fondamentale pour le
destin de la france
ce n'est pas de la tactique ce que je
fais c'est pas pour imiter donald trump
c'est parce que si vous voulez j'ai
attendu vainement voyez depuis je vous
disais 1990 la conversion de la droite
j'ai attendu vainement que un homme
politique je dirais traditionnels se
lève et et efface la campagne que j'ai
fait depuis six mois j'ai attendu trente
ans ccg j'ai quand même montré une
certaine patience est arrivé là je me
suis dit que aucun ne le ferait donc je
me suis décidé à le faire monnaie lui
n'a pas brillé lors de ces campagnes
électorales mais il vous a longtemps
impressionner et d'une certaine façon
inspirée vladimir poutine en 2014 il
vient d'annexer la crimée vous l'avait
désigné homme de l'année et vous en
expliquer à l'émission c'est à vous
- d'abord j'estime que c'est un patriote
russe et que pour ça il défend les
intérêts de son pays et c'est ça que
j'admire d'abord chez lui comme
j'admirais le général de gaulle qui a dû
quitter un patriote français qui
défendait ses intérêts je dis pas
continer général de gaulle à fouras sûr
mais c'est ça que je veux dire quand et
comment il est là pour ça pour défendre
les intérêts de son pays deuxièmement
je pense que l'europe a fait un pas de
clerc avec cet accord d'association avec
l'ukraine je suis désolé on a on a il
faut pas oublier que l'ukraine et la
russie depuis des siècles sont ensemble
que la russie estime que l'ukraine lui
appartient que
le la crimée et russes depuis le xviiie
siècle freine géographiquement et en
europe mais la russie est aussi dans une
partie de la rue si osi est ce que il y
avait beaucoup de questions mais j'ai
envie de vous demander est ce que au
contraire au vu de cette guerre absurde
criminelle et destructrice pour son
propre pays poutine n'apparaît pas comme
un piètre patriotes
en tout cas manifestement il s'est
trompé en s'ils pensaient qu'ils
allaient gagner une guerre éclair d'où
ma question absolument donc si vous
voulez
il faut voir que ce que je disais là
beaucoup de gens le disaient à l'époque
nicolas sarkozy le disait jacques chirac
l'avait dit bien avant moi
pas avec le côté
admiratif je vous assure je vous assure
que si vous savez c'est jacques chirac
qui lui remet la légion d'honneur
poutine qui lui qui lui remet aussi la
plus grande médaille russe il était il
avait vraiment une très grande amitié
l'un l'autre l'un pour l'autre nicolas
sarkozy aussi a fait des éloges de
vladimir poutine et de la russie dans
franchement
et françois fillon aussi c'est la trappe
d'ailleurs sorti approuvé l'annexion de
la grille mais aussi ici même sarkozy a
approuvé la de la laddh a demandé la
levée des sanctions mais il n'approuvait
pas là je vous inspire ce qu'il a pu non
mais franchement l'annexion de la crimée
on peut la critiquer parce que c'est un
acte militaire mais on ne peut pas nier
que la crimée étaient russes depuis la
tsarine catherine 2 ce comme la lorraine
en france à peu près la même époque
voyez au xviiie siècle bon voilà ça
c'est un fait
c'est une violation de souvent c'est ce
que je vous dis et c'est ce que je vous
dis mais c'est pour n'est d'accord mais
vous m'accordez que elles étaient russes
depuis le xviiie siècle et que l a été
donnée vous connaissez les circonstances
un soir de beuverie par khrouchtchev
qu'il a donné à l'ukraine à une époque
où de toute façon ukraine russie tout ça
c'était dans l'ensemble soviétique il
faut il faut remettre dans le contexte
pour être tout à fait honnête
voilà donc donc maintenant effectivement
poutine s'est trompé
poutine
n'a pas eu la guerre éclair qu'il rêve
dont il rêvait
jeu si vous voulez voilà je continue de
de penser qu'on pouvait éviter cette
guerre qu'on pouvait éviter cette guerre
si on avait décidé si les américains
avaient accepté que l'ukraine
füle
ne fut jamais
ils n'ont comprendre que vous ne pouvez
jamais en prévoir l'entrée de l'ukraine
dans l'otan et que l avait un statut en
gros de neutralité c'est vous avez vu
dans le figaro la semaine dernière
maurice gourdault-montagne le conseiller
diplomatique de jacques chirac qui a
révélé que c'est ce qu'avait proposé
jacques chirac en 2006 et que la russie
avait accepté et que les américains ont
alors refusé au nom de la fameuse
théorie dite de la porte ouverte qui
prévoit toujours plus d'avancer vers
l'est de l'otan on va revenir à de
gaulle dans quelques minutes au
soviétisme d'ailleurs avant cela une une
madeleine que nous avons choisis pour
vous
c'est un personnage de littérature
lucien de rubempré le héros d'illusions
perdues de balzac dont vous avez repris
le nom pour baptiser la maison d'édition
qui a édité votre dernier livre rubin
près un jeune provincial qui monte à
paris rêve d'être écrivain et devient
journaliste
cela ne fait pas le poids
enfin monsieur je vous entends parler
d'un livre comme d'un paquet de café ou
d'un sac de pommes de terre
la peine le talent la vie d'un homme
sont dans un livre ça ne compte pas un
livre est une marchandise perdez vos
illusions jeune homme le talent c'est un
long faites-vous d'abord un nom est
revenu à l'heure avec votre talent nous
lirons peut-être pas vos ouvrages mais
en vous les terrains
on voit bien ce qui vous fascine
chérubins près sa fulgurante ascension
sociale mais souvenant pas seulement pas
seulement si vous me permettez alors je
vous en prie son talent littéraire
souvenez-vous que il a vraiment du
talent littéraire
son talent de journaliste car ils
percent très vite son culot son culot
absolument mais c'est pas ce qui me
fascine le plus
mais et puis et puis paris vous oublié
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire paris la france
la littérature la langue française cette
vie à paris vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire que moi depuis que je
suis jeune quand je me balade dans paris
et que je vois tu es l'immeuble tel
monument je me dis ah ben là c'est tel
roman de balzac là c'est tel roman de
stendhal là c'est louis saez a été
guillotiné la lah bonaparte a mis ses
canons voyez paris la france mais paris
avant de retourner à angoulême parce que
ça n'a
duré qu'un temps avez vous oublié sa
déchéance n'est pas oublié mais accordez
moi accordez-moi que même s'il échoue et
s'il échoue piteusement il est quand
même un personnage plus romantique et
plus charmant que rastignac qui lui
réussit puisqu'il deviendra ministre
mais qu'ils renoncent à tout qui devient
un politicien
cynique accordez moi que quand on a 14
ans quand je découvre donc ce livre
henri bas après c'est quand même plus
plus fascinant est plus séduisant que 2d
mais rubin près que plutôt que des mets
rastignac ou même que d'aimer vautrin le
bandit de grand chemin cynique et
évidemment que c'est votre inca raison
évidemment que c'est rastignac qu'à
raison et ce sont eux qui gagnent mais
quand on est adolescent on préfère les
les bovins qu aux vainqueurs cynique
voilà même si le finit mal voilà un
homme que vous avez très souvent cités
dans cette campagne un grand homme donc
1961 après l'édification du mur de
berlin charles de gaulle à propos de
l'impérialisme soviétique
que les soviets 16 de menaces et
qu'il aide
la détente à s'établir au lieu de
l'empêcher
qu'il favorise une atmosphère
international pacifique
tandis ce qui la rendait tout fente
alors il sera possible aux trois
puissance de l'occident
d'étudier avec eux tous les problèmes du
monde et notamment
celui de l'allemagne dans ce 2 goals
acquis entre washington et moscou a
toujours choisi son camp atlantiste vous
vous reconnaissez aussi à je pense que
vous vous trompez sur un mot simplement
toujours lequel toujours le mot toujours
dans votre phrase c'est le mot toujours
qui est fou on est en 61
le général de gaulle a proposé aux
américains depuis 1958 une direction à 3
de l'otan
etats-unis angleterre france les
américains vont rejeter cette
proposition avec mépris puis le général
de gaulle en 1963 propose une alliance
avec l'allemagne d'adenauer
une alliance qui s'émanciperait de la
tutelle américaine
les allemands au parlement allemands
font voter un préambule à ce texte
d'alliance entre la france et
l'allemagne qui rappelle que l'alliance
privilégiée de l'allemagne c'est l'otan
et les états unis fureur
fureur2 du général de gaulle qui dit à
alain peyrefitte que les alliances les
traités sont faits pour que ce que
vivent les roses c'est à dire le temps
d'une journée d'accord attendez attendez
j'ai pas fini j'ai pas fini parce que si
vous voulez je vous remets tout dans ce
contexte non mais moi je vous parle en
1900 mais vous auriez pu attendez
attendez pas rejouer très vite et je
voulais aller des attendez attendez vous
auriez pu reprendre un autre discours en
1967 de du général du mmm général de
gaulle à phnom penh dans lequel il
fustige l' impérialisme américain donc
le général de gaulle il a une pensée
complète que vous ne pouvez pas réduire
à une minute dans une conférence de
presse en 1961 absolument mais je
maintiens ma phrase dans les périodes de
tension une configuration son nom les
missiles de cuba en soit une une annonce
de ce fait quel autre qu'elle tient
alors de berlin on vient de passer les
classes et la même période tous à
68 en 1960 les périodes de tensions
entre washington et moscou il a toujours
choisi son langue et pas de celui pas
des amériques en 1944 il va voir staline
pour justement se rapprocher de la
russie de staline vous m'entendez parce
que il veut s'émanciper des américains
en 1968 lorsque les chars soviétiques
rentrer à prague il continue sa
politique qu'il appelait à l'époque
détente entente coopération avec l'est
il va en visite officielle en roumanie
pour continuer justement à essayer de se
rapprocher de l'est donc pardonnez moi
oui il est un allié fidèle de l'occident
de l'amérique parce que il sait qu'il ne
veut pas se retrouver face soumis à
l'impérialisme soviétique communiste à
l'époque ils sont communistes il faut
jamais l'oublier mais en revanche dès
que la menace communiste s'effondre et
même avant puisque même alors qu'il les
chars russes rentrer à prague en ou pas
l'été 1968 il veut absolument
s'émanciper de la tutelle américaine et
je pense si vous vous et que sans faire
parler un mort si
après la chute du mur de berlin après la
chute du communisme il aurait proposé
comme d'ailleurs l'a fait françois
mitterrand vous voyez une confédération
qui correspondait le mieux à sa vision
de l'europe comme il l'avait dit lui
même de l'atlantique à l'oural voyez
l'europe de l'atlantique à l'oural donc
le général ne fait pas du général de
gaulle un atlantiste ne fait pas du
général de gaulle quelqu'un qui est
soumis aux états unis qui n'est pas
soumis d'ailleurs à la russie et encore
moins à l'urss c'est quelqu'un c'est un
patriote français qui défend
l'indépendance de la france et qu'ils
pensent que l'indépendance de la france
s'affirme aura mieux à équidistance d
impérialisme américain et russe et
soviétique
c'est ça la stratégie du général de
gaulle et c'est celle dans laquelle je
me suis toujours inscrits personne n'a
dit qu'il était soumis mais je ne suis
pas certain du mot équidistance que vous
n'êtes prononcer mais la joie je pense
que vous avez tort
rubriques suivantes
180° la séquence des changements de cap
vous avez voté vous l'avait dit pour
françois mitterrand 1981 et plus
étonnant encore vous avez voté à nouveau
pour lui en 88 vous aviez pourtant le
choix entre un candidat issu de la avec
un candidat issu de la droite classique
jacques chirac extrait de leur
affrontement de l'entre-deux tours je
souhaite monsieur mitterrand que vous et
votre parti ayez la même conception de
l'impartialité de l'état que celle que
j'ai toujours eu et qui a toujours eu le
mouvement auquel jacques je vous ai
observé pendant deux ans vous me donnez
là un bien mauvais exemple mais je ne
vais pas m'engager davantage
moi je veux je vous appelle je ne fais
aucune observation particulière sur
votre façon de vous exprimer vous en
avez le droit moi je continuais vous
appeler monsieur le premier ministre
puisque c'est comme cela que je vous ai
appelé pendant deux ans et que vous
l'être et bien en tant que premier
ministre j'ai constaté que vous aviez et
c'est bien juste le dire le très réelles
qualités vous n'est pas celle de
l'impartialité et du sens de la justice
dans la conduite de l'état
permettez moi juste de vous dire que ce
soir
je ne suis pas le premier ministre et
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
république nous sommes deux candidats à
égalité
et qu'ils se soumettent au jugement des
français
seuls qui comptent vous me permettrez
donc de vous appeler monsieur mitterrand
et vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur
le premier ministre
pourquoi mitterrand et chirac
jeu d'abord parce que je viens si vous
voulez comme j'avais voté mitterrand en
81 jeu
socialement je me sentais dans le le le
vous voulez le camp des petits d'où je
venais voyez c'était une sociologie et
j'avais l'impression du du mépris de
classe de giscard à l'époque et en 88
je n'avais pas confiance dans chirac jeu
d'ailleurs j'ai écrit plus tard des
livres assez l'homme une semaine l'homme
qui ne s'aimait pas tant en 2002
exactement et je n'avais pas confiance
en lui je n'avais pas confiance en ses
revirements incessants
et vous avez plus confiant sans nom en
mitterrand non pas du tout pas du tout
donc vous avez raison je n'avais pas
plus confiance en mitterrand mais il
fallait bien fallait bien choisir
je cherchais ma voix je vais vous dire
honnêtement en 88 je n'ai pas encore
trouvé ma voie politique d'ailleurs tout
ça est assez cohérent puisque on a vu au
début de notre conversation le
basculement qui a été pour moi
1989 puis ensuite donc il y a eu 89 le
voile de creil puis ensuite il ya eu 92
le référendum sur maastricht où là je
m'inscris petit à petit au fur et à
mesure de la campagne dans le camp du
non voyez ensuite il ya une logique dans
tout ça rubrique zéro pointé à présent
des provocations des excès nous n'avons
pas eu de mal à en trouver certains vous
ont même mené devant les tribunaux trois
condamnations plusieurs procédures
toujours en cours
eric zemmour esquisse un sourire le
chroniqueur se veut confiant mais se
refuse à tout commentaire à la barre le
journaliste et combatif il maintient les
propos qu'il a tenus en mars dernier
lors d'un débat télévisé
poursuivez pour diffamation il n'ya
pourtant rien de condamnable aux yeux
d'eric zemmour la parole d'eric
zemmour n'a jamais été une parole
raciste
c'est une parole libre la société a
évolué et a changé le seuil de tolérance
n'est plus le même et bien s'agissant
des propos d'eric zemmour c'est
exactement la même chose nous ne voulons
pas évidemment jeté l'anathème sur eric
zemmour c'est pas ça le sujet la
question est de savoir quelle est celle
de la responsabilité d'un meneur de
débats ou d'un chroniqueur qui est un
leader d'opinion
n'at-il pas en même temps que des droits
des devoirs est ce que vous sentez
aujourd'hui en conflit contre la justice
non je ne suis pas en conflit contre la
justice vous savez vous avez dit j'étais
condamné trois fois non j'ai deux fois
définitivement oui mais une fois
attendait une procédure en appel voilà
et là la première fois j'ai été condamné
en 2011 je n'ai pas voulu faire appel
mais seraient d'accord la deuxième fois
j'ai été condamné vous avez raison
définitivement mais en france ma
procédure continue devant la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme mais
peu importe
la première fois donc la seule fois la
vraie condamnation la véritable
condamnation pardon c'est pour avoir dit
que la plupart des délinquants étaient
noirs et arabes
dans un débat franchement toute la
france pansard aujourd'hui tout le monde
le sait je n'ai été condamné que pour d
avoir dit la vérité donc je ne suis pas
en conflit avec la justice je ne suis en
tout cas pas en conflit avec la vérité
et je ne suis pas en conflit avec ce que
pense le peuple français maintenant il y
a effectivement deux choses une loi qui
a été une loi dite plevent de 72 qui a
été dévoyé par des juges de gauche pour
en faire une arme politique pour
ostracisés et pour
punir une dp propos contre l'immigration
pour qui dénonce la délinquance
étrangère où la délinquance est immigré
d'où ma question
votre guerre contre la justice donc
c'est pas une guerre c'est simplement le
chaussant sol et ise de gauche oui alors
si vous voulez si vous voulez contre eux
je suis dans un conflit politique
puisque eux mêmes font de la politique
et instrumentalise la justice pour me
combattre politiquement donc moi je les
combats politiques si vous voulez une
archive que nous proposons à tous les
candidats celle de l' alerte verte
c'est l'élection présidentielle de 74
nous avait 16 ans peut-être vous
souvenez-vous de gier le candidat s'est
ouverte à élise monsieur dumont avec le
verre d'eau
et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes animaux
il passait pour un hurluberlu à l'époque
mais il n'avait pas tort il a fait un
coup absolument magnifique je m'en
souviens très bien parce que j'étais
passionné de politique à l'époque et
donc je suivais ça avec avec avec
passion je suivais tous les débats
politiques les giscard mitterrand etc et
tous les autres ça vous a pas ancré dans
l'écologie printemps n'ont pas du tout
d'ailleurs il se trompait il disait
avant la fin du siècle on est vingt ans
après le siècle et on ne manque pas
d'eau et personne ne manque d'eau alors
qu'il y ait des problèmes écologiques
qu'il y ait un réchauffement climatique
très bien mais je vous dire très mal
mais en tout cas il se trompait dans la
prédiction de quelques années c'est ni
seulement commandes de quelques décès
mais vous n'en savez rien vous n'en
savez rien moi je ne pense pas qu'on
manquera d'eau
je pense je crois je crois à deux choses
je crois à l'adaptabilité
infinie de la de l'espèce humaine et je
crois au génie humain qui va trouver des
solutions techniques comme il a toujours
trouvé comme il a toujours trouvé pour
se sortir des situations qui paraissent
des impasses donc si vous voulez sur ça
je crois profondément maintenant ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
difficultés de crise voyez de deux
catastrophes mais
moi je pense si vous voulez que la
catastrophe qui menace la france ce
n'est pas une catastrophe écologique
mais c'est une catastrophe démographique
et c'est un remplacement de population
et un remplacement de civilisations sur
notre sol je pense que en 2050 la
population française sera à majorité
musulmane voire africaine et que donc ça
ne sera plus la france et que c'est pour
cela que je me suis présenté à la
président à l'élection présidentielle et
c'est pour cela que je me bats pour
empêcher cela voyez chacun à ces
catastrophes ces prédictions moi c'est
la catastrophe que je vois venir est qui
et qui me taraude le plus parce que je
suis attachée d'abord à la france enfin
une rencontre
[Musique]
en voyageant dans les archives de l'ina
nous avons retrouvé ce moment d'histoire
de la télévision et de la france nous
sommes en
1976 la célèbre émission les dossiers de
l'écran consacre un débat à pétain c'est
la première fois que ce sujet débattu à
la télévision française sur le plateau
l'avocat du maréchal pétain jacques
isorni face à des résistants comme henri
fresnay et pierre henri teitgen il faut
voir ce que chat était sur le terrain la
collaboration
on arrache des petits enfants juifs à
leurs parents
et ce sont des gendarmes français
et des miliciens français de vichy qui
participent à ces rats ou non mais 4000
au camp de ranchi de mes yeux de mes
yeux j'ai vu débarquer pendant des
semaines des trains au camp de gurs dans
les basses pyrénées des gauches de 4 à
12 ans par centaines et par centaines
toutes les semaines pleurant et bt on
n'avait pas pris leur nom on ne savait
pas le nom de leurs parents des
gendarmes français les couches et grands
le camp comme un troupeau des pauvres
petits mots tout seuls leurs en hurlant
rappelant leur mère et qu'est ce qu'on
en a fait au nom de la collaboration
sous le nom du maréchal pétain sous sa
responsabilité politique et morale
qu'est ce qu'on en a fait tous ces
petits juifs et bien dans les semaines
qui ont suivi on les a envoyés aux
allemands pour qui les brûle à mathausen
et house but c'était ça la collaboration
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise
tout cela est vrai
je voudrais simplement rappeler je ne le
nie pas je ne les jamais nié je voulais
simplement rappelé que la france avait
perdu la guerre
en 1940 et que à partir de là elle était
soumise à l'allemagne et que donc quand
les policiers français arrêtent les
enfants juifs
c'est sur ordre des allemands
par ailleurs ce que j'ai simplement dit
c'est que ces juifs étaient des juifs
étrangers ça ne veut pas dire que
évidemment il fallait les tuer ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il fallait évidemment
leur prendre leurs enfants etc vous
connaissez l'histoire mais je connais
très bien cet historien allemand n'avait
pas réclamé des enfants mais attendez
attendez à temps les allemands n'avaient
pas réclamé il voulait il voulait soit
une soyez juste les allemands voulaient
beaucoup plus de juifs beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus les français leur en
donner beaucoup moins les allemands
étaient furieux ou d'ailleurs même pour
la rafle du vél dit mais tout ça est
dérisoire par rapport à la mort de tous
ses enfants à la mort de tous ces gens
et c'est ce que j'ai dit simplement vous
savez moi les querelles historiques
m'intéresse me passionne alors j'ai
parlé de ce sujet j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à dire j'ai expliqué la
situation je continue de penser ce que
je pense ça ne veut pas dire que je
réhabilite pétain comme les tous les les
imbéciles disent ça veut dire que
j'essaye d'être objectif
historiquement on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec moi et pour d'autres
sujets aussi je peux parler des heures
de la conquête de la russie par napoléon
je peux parler des heures de jeanne
d'arc etc il faut pouvoir parler de
sujets historiques d'ailleurs vous voyez
à l'époque on peut parler comme ça
librement et sereinement de tous ces
sujets même si c'est affreux et même si
c'est horrible ça n'était pas si serein
que ça sur ce cas en tout cas on allait
sur cet ennemi accordez moi que c'était
pas censuré non ce n'était pas sans
aller jusque jeudi les témoins de
l'époque
était il y avait des survivants mais
bien sûr que je comprends je comprends
mais tout ça mais vous savez tout ça est
évidemment horrible je ne vais pas
commencer à me dire que tout ça est
négligeable je n'ai je n'ai jamais dit
cela j'essaye de faire je sais j'ai
essayé de faire la part des choses et
d'expliquer une situation historique
au terme de cet adn de ce voyage dans
les archives de l'ina y at il un morceau
essentiel de votre adn eric zemmour que
nous aurions oublié d'évoquer
écouter
non je réfléchis j'ai été étonné que
vous si vous relancer ma carrière entre
guillemets médiatique vous n'aviez pas
parler il n'y a pas eu d' exemples pris
dans les émission d'on n'est pas couché
de laurent ruquier qui était quand même
parfois assez spectaculaire est assez
amusante voilà c'était pour pour
détendre parce que on s'amusait bien et
je crois que les spectateurs s'amusent
et bien il y avait en plus
on faisait à la fois de la politique et
on défend des avec naulleau une certaine
idée de de la littérature de l'art et je
pense que ce n'était pas ce n'était pas
négligeable d'ailleurs cheveux pour vous
amuser
j'ai retrouvé beaucoup aujourd'hui deux
jeunes gens qui m'ont découvert à ce
moment là et qui me disent qu'ils ont
été formés par mois politiquement
culturellement essayé je dirais que ça
j'avoue que ça me fait plaisir vous
voyez j'ai éduqué entre guillemets comme
un grand frère ou comme un père toute
une génération de jeunes gens à qui j'ai
transmis mon amour de la france mon
amour de l'histoire mon amour des grands
hommes de notre pays après voilà on
et je pense que ça c'est c'est quand
même quelque chose dont je suis fier
merci merci à eric zemmour
[Musique]